all right so this video happened in
mexico
it's the cartel yeah
[Music]
see that okay there's some people that
would have been dead
right there and then dead dead real real
quick
panic just crossed the border not long
ago yeah
got to a stop light yeah and they rushed
yeah they can spot you
it's because he was driving a truck yes
trucks are very valuable
yes so they try to rob yes and the
reason why i'm playing this video is
just to show you guys how quickly things
change from like a normal drive to
is it why are they stopping is a car
accident no this man understood some
shifty was going on
very good on him for his quick driving
he managed to not hit anyone which
didn't escalate the situation but he got
out of there safely
good because you don't know what would
happen maybe they were taking them
hostage maybe they would have just
stolen the truck
maybe they would have killed both of
them we don't know do we want
how fast how long was that 45 seconds
tops
reflex it's basically knowing what the
vibe is what
what does the first thing did you turn
going back to america
back to america back up because how do
you gone deeper
not today it might have been worse and
if he wasn't in a border town
right if he was somewhere deeper there
might have been nowhere for you to run
because you're in their territory not
today that's what that was it
if not today was someone that was it
oh not today let me back up what is this
the cartel shut the [ __ ] up let me
handle this
man's went straight into action boom
reverse
boom let me finally leave out because he
knew then they pulled in the second car
the second car was activated to try to
trap him in yeah
very good yeah i mentioned this because
things like checkpoints are very common
in foreign countries
and checkpoints are not like not
checkpoints by the police no
no not not those kind of checkpoints
what checkpoints
oh well we're safe no not those kind of
checkpoints i got some friends in brazil
at night they don't stop at lights and
they live there
i got some friends in detroit they saw
they see a light
they don't stop they run it because
there's places where you're not supposed
to stay
ready it's dangerous to stop at a red
light think about that police will tell
you
yep run it yep that's not a violation
that's a trap run it run that light
your that red light's a hazard run that
light red isn't stopped red is danger
exactly it's a different thing
foreign
[Music]
yeah we've actually encountered
i counted it so many times when i was
living in ethiopia and that's where like
corruption comes into place
sometimes and you got to pay people off
to get through places right
money is what makes people move but
when we got there [ __ ] sorry
i have flashbacks hey you want to go to
that store you go on the patreon that's
a crazy story
but it's yo i'm telling you checkpoints
are not meant to be messed with
vigilances and this is what this i i was
kind of trying to touch on in another
video in regards to like
what it's like when chaos is the norm
when chaos is the norm you got to get
ready for a situation like that
because i can assure you i know a lot of
people who would have froze in that
situation
or would have stopped and rolled down
the window abba you're done
you're doing it again you're doing what
that you're victim blaming sure yeah
i love victim yes i enjoy it because
when you're from that country or
wherever
from that place there's no such thing as
victim blaming
victim blaming is actually what you have
to do
in order not to become a victim but go
ahead
call it victim blame it if you want yeah
take precautions such a privilege yes
you got to take questions but
again quick thinking and this is one
situation where not using a gun was
maybe the best situation possible the
only reason that because if you would
have fired if
they might have just laced the whole
thing cause you don't even know what you
don't even know
no did you hear the man say cartel
yeah did you hear the man say cartel but
that's what i'm saying
it's not always obvious what the
solution is he now he chose the best one
out of a hundred different solutions you
might have drove him deeper into
territory he might have taken the wrong
turn he might have been stopped by
people he might
have ran them over trying to kill one
and each of these could have led to a
completely different outcome
and so i always take an interest in
watching situations like this because
i'm like
what's the best way out what's sensible
what can you do
that will most often lead to good
conclusions and this is also why
some people just have situational
awareness on at all times
so i do this a lot when i talk to vets
but uh sometimes they'll tell me like
and you can ask a bunch of veterans
they'll tell you this a lot of them have
the same habits you eat fast
you sit uh you don't sit in a booth you
sit on access
close to the exit someplace where you
have your back towards the wall or
something you can see everything that's
happening around you like
that kind of stuff happens to people
where they're situationally aware
i can assure you that that guy as he was
coming to that intersection
had danger already on his mind because
he didn't even give him a chance to try
to play him
he was already like all right how am i
going to do this and he was calculating
in his head
most people if you can't sense a danger
ahead you don't know how to make that
adjustment
so the best thing is prevention you
you're always ready
and that's why i'm trying to say it's a
different it's a different mindset and
it's little science
yes it's little sign that you have
photogenitis nothing
but if you're an area where people run
lights and there's people at the lights
right there there's not supposed to be
people there yep that's
that's a checkpoint not a safe one
so just something to to watch it i
thought this video was uh
very telling it was short it was
straight to the point and it was
a tremendous amount of danger and it's
important for people to know that these
kinds of things exist
not to let your life be governed by it
but sometimes being situationally aware
can be the difference between lying and
living
and that's all it comes down to so
hopefully these guys uh you guys enjoyed
this video
there's another channel called active
self defense that does like a lot of
these kind of videos and
i think they're fascinating so yeah
those are my thoughts there's anything
else you want to sound like self-defense
and stuff like that
oh yeah if you're not used to these
kinds of environments and you're going
to these kind of environments
get yourself a guide get yourself a
local get yourself somebody who's used
to dealing with this stuff
there are fixers there are enforcers
there are people that can take care of
this for you
trust me they're absolutely necessary
you know
we know first hand i'm not even shout
out to delgado
that's the shout out today all right we
know firsthand my [ __ ]
we assisted but if it wasn't for him
would we even be here today we don't
even know we don't we don't even know
but i'm not laughing because this is
funny yeah i'm laughing because to me
this is obvious and it's so not obvious
to a lot of people yeah
but it's very obvious but whatever yeah
so let us know what you guys think in
the comments below
[Music]
is